(rock band music)
(crowd applauding)
(light music)
- [Narrator] Garut in
Western Java, Indonesia,
is a quiet place.
(children giggling)
Well, most of the time.
(rock band music)
- [Narrator] Rebellion,
teenagers, rules and tradition.
It's an age-old rock and roll story,
but this time, with hijabs.
Meet the VoB, Indonesia's Metal Hijabis.
(girls laughing)
There's Firdda, the
vocalist and guitarist,
who loves hip-hop.
Ouidi, the drummer, a Red
Hot Chili Peppers aficionado.
Then you got C.T. on the bass,
who likes her thrash metal bands
like Lamb of God and System of a Down.
(rock band music)
(metal band music)
- [Narrator] Since its start in 2014,
the band has seen some success,
but not without its critics.
(rock band music)